[Music]
each of these pins is a Bed Bath and
Beyond that closed in 2022 that's about
20 of its stores Shares are at their
lowest point since the 90s after the
company said it's facing bankruptcy
bankruptcy bankruptcy as sales collapsed
Bed Bath and Beyond scrambled to cut
costs by laying off workers and closing
those stores here's what happened to the
Home Goods chain in the last six months
that led to a cash crisis and a
potential bankruptcy filing
let's turn back the clock to June when
Bed Bath and Beyond CEO Mark Trenton had
a problem his strategy of scaling back
coupons and doing away with popular
National brands in favor of private
labels was failing these are some of my
favorites from The Haven line and the
company was struggling to stock shelves
since it had fallen behind on payments
to vendors sales had fallen by 25
compared to the previous year and net
losses were up to over 350 million
dollars
on June 29th the company announced a
leadership change Sue Gove has been
named interim chief executive officer
replacing Mark Tritton who is leaving
the company at the time Gove said that
bed bath and Beyonds results are not up
to our expectations nor are they
reflective of our potential it was not
entirely surprising because the company
had reported a string of poor earnings
and falling sales and so it was well
known that the company was struggling in
August cash reserves key for paying
vendors were still low the company
needed more cash and was looking for a
loan to make that happen on the 23rd Bed
Bath and Beyond announced it had secured
500 million dollars in funding which it
hoped would help keep shelves stocked
some vendors had not been paid in months
and clearly the company was struggling
while the loan could pay for more
inventory it wasn't enough to keep every
store open Bed Bath and Beyond announced
it'd be closing 150 locations about 20
percent of its stores plus it would be
starting layoffs that amounted to a
fifth of its corporate and supply chain
staff
just two days later the company suffered
a different kind of loss CFO Gustavo
Arnold died by Suicide
at a time when a company is struggling
financially to lose your CFO that like
that is you know is certainly a shock
and it certainly made things even more
difficult for them when second quarter
earnings were released at the end of
September analysts said the company was
facing yet another cash crunch the 500
million dollar loan had weakened Bed
Bath and Beyond's balance sheet with
liabilities exceeding assets
still the company felt confident that
our current liquidity will enable the
necessary strategic plans we have
implemented but a few weeks later Bed
Bath and Beyond announced it'd be making
a debt exchange offer where a company
exchanges bonds for secured notes to
extend maturities and reduce interest
expenses the company was offering higher
interest rates in exchange for investors
taking a haircut on their principal it
meant note holders would lose money but
they'd be guaranteed something stock
prices dipped then fell more after gov
hosted a summit with suppliers at the
company's New Jersey headquarters to ask
for support she had several challenges
one players some of them had not been
paid in months and two the company had
pushed out some of these suppliers to
make way for its private label Brands
now it wanted the suppliers to come back
well these suppliers had found other
channels to sell their goods so it was
taking a lot of convincing to get the
suppliers back on board and I'm not sure
they were entirely successful these
vendor woes were all happening before
the busiest time of the year for
retailers the holiday season Bed Bath
and Beyond was still struggling to stock
shelves just a few days before black
Friday reports came out that more than
40 percent of the retailers products had
been out of stock in October some
suppliers said they were still owed
money and would pause shipments until
they were paid if you had empty shelves
you're not going to have people coming
in and buying and then you're not going
to have sales and it becomes a vicious
cycle sales didn't meet expectations
during the fourth quarter and on January
5th Bed Bath and Beyond announced it was
preparing to file for bankruptcy in just
a few weeks a spokeswoman for Bed Bath
and Beyond said it hadn't made any final
decisions and Gove said on the third
quarter earnings call we are committed
to to updating all stakeholders of our
plans as they develop and finalize in
that earnings report the company said
sales fell 33 percent and losses Rose to
393 million dollars our business was
built around our loyal customers
listening and responding to their
preferences was at the center veering
away from that path has led to our
recent financial performance the company
also said it is planning more layoffs in
an effort to cut costs bankruptcy is
still not a certainty but their ability
to avoid it is shrinking you know there
were things they could have done such as
sell their Buy Buy Baby chain for cash
and they chose not to do that so their
options are narrowing news of an
official bankruptcy filing could come in
the next few weeks
[Music]